Welcome to the Ann and Ashley show.
I'm Ashley, none Ann.
And we're here at Connor's clinic.
Our topic today is going to be on biodynamic wine.
So we're gonna discuss what it is,
where it comes from, how it's made,
and why we should care about it.
But before we get started,
please make sure to like, subscribe, and share our content.
If you're on YouTube, hit the little alert buttons
so you don't miss an episode.
So Ann, what is the difference between organic
and biodynamic wine?
Yes, so organic wine is used with organic grapes,
certified organic grapes.
There's no added sulfites in organic wine.
There's no fertilizers, pesticides, herbicides,
or GMOs.
Biodynamic wine is also all of that.
So no chemicals, no sulfites.
But it takes everything a step further
and incorporating the idea that the whole farm
is part of the larger ecosystem.
And then it takes measures to support the whole ecosystem.
So essentially you end up with a better grape.
So I thought that was pretty interesting.
That's super cool.
So biodynamic farming actually began 20 years
before organic farming.
So it was like the origin to organic farms.
So how it's made is going to be utilizing
the whole ecosystem that you just mentioned
as far as nourishing the grapes.
And then it also uses the compost to fertilize
and that includes having a biodiversity is required for that.
So different crops and animals on that farm as well.
They also follow a very strict calendar.
So that lets them know when to harvest, prune, and water.
And then of course, one to let nature just take its course.
And then this leaves the grapes
in the most healthier and vital form as well.
But who cares about biodynamic wine?
We just want to drink wine, right?
Well, most people do, but really,
it is important to think about things,
not only a wine, the foods that we're eating as well,
and how it is grown because things can be riddled
with pesticides and all these chemicals that we buy
and have a hard time getting rid of.
We all live in this world where we are exposed
to so many different toxins that we're taxing our body.
And so if we make a responsible choice in choosing things
that are lower on the toxicity scale,
we're only doing things to benefit our bodies.
So we should be concerned.
And also, of course, the whole ecological perspective
in respecting that birth, respecting the land,
usually the land in a better condition.
I mean, that's over-future-generated.
We have to be aware of that as well.
So, and then also, when we're talking about genes
and chemicals, I mean, not talking about genes,
but to brand now into the conversation,
because that's part of what we do here at Congress.
Because talking about genetics,
we have gene detoxification genes and detoxification pathways.
And some people have a lot of variants on these pathways,
so it's harder for them to get rid of the large chemicals
that we are exposed to.
So being mindful of that, and again,
choosing things that are less toxic burden can help your body.
And then cell fights as well.
Sometimes people get flushed in the face when they drink wine
or they feel like they just can't drink wine
because they feel sick from it.
That could be because of the cell fights in the wine.
So, again, the biodynamic lines do not have added cell fights.
There's going to be some that are produced naturally
in the fermentation process of creating the wine,
but there's no additional cell fights.
So, that's great as well.
So, it all is supposed to be cleaner, healthier,
and hopefully not give the hangover event you can
if you just get a really cheap chemical late in your mind.
So, yes.
So, that's why we should care.
That is why we should care, you're right.
So, we have two different wines here.
We have a white and a red.
There's a really cool label on the back of these ones
in particularly.
So, and read off what this cool label says.
So, these are both from a Benzinger family winery.
So, Benzinger is the brand.
And it says our family pioneered certified sustainable farming
35 years ago because it's the best way
to grow delicious exceptional grapes
with the cycles of nature.
Our vineyards are home to sheep,
cows, birds, and butterflies
who create a vibrant natural ecosystem.
The result is thriving vines with rich, juicy grapes
that are full of flavor.
So, this chardonnay boasts a creamy texture
with layered notes of pear, apricot, and lemon.
That sounds good.
Yeah, sounds pretty delicious.
Yeah, I really like that they put that on there.
This chardonnay is layered with notes
of berry, cobbler, mocha, and spice.
So, that sounds good too.
That sounds good, that's completely different.
All right, so then we have never had this kind of biodynamic,
I've never had biodynamic wine ever.
But, she's too young.
She's, yeah, she's young.
She is a good age.
We are.
I was just gonna say, just to clarify.
I don't know why they're yet, I'm just kidding.
Okay, so, but I am an inexperienced wine drinker.
I thought it'll open up.
Well, if you need help, I can.
Okay, yeah, you'll have to.
I have to.
Actually, I'm just gonna stab this in here first.
I wasn't supposed to open this, talk her right?
Cool.
That's the only funer me.
You know, I always say if you can't open the valuation drinker.
Wow, that's the practice.
Love me, help me with that.
So, then we can drink it, yeah.
We have to try it.
So, too quickly.
I mean, I don't know if this was gonna try to cut it,
but I did.
But, that one, it's a dull end.
Yeah, it's not very, there we go.
Oh, you got it.
See, more wines in her day than mine.
I had a little more practice with wine drinking.
All right, yeah, it's not very,
stupid, sturdy.
Are you a good porter?
I'm so good at calling.
Okay, good, because it's a light table.
Yes, there we go.
Look at you go.
We're getting there.
Oh, it's time to see what's that.
Oh, yeah, my back and the little one.
Yeah.
Stuffed up.
Or, yeah.
Okay, maybe I don't have as much experience as I thought.
We'll get there.
Oh, my people, does it take at your house to open
the bottle of wine?
Look at it.
Progress.
Woo!
You can get that.
That was intense.
He saved the video.
That was a workout, I think we deserve the wine now.
I think so too.
Okay, so I'm going to let you part
because I will spill 100 bucks to do this.
I'm good, yeah.
It's on the carpet, that's fine.
Yeah, it's just okay now.
There you go.
Oh, thank you.
I'll agree a little bit.
Do you have a wine preference?
White or red?
I'm trying to both.
No, but in general.
Oh, no.
I don't.
I'm going to try the white one first.
Okay, I'll try the white one too.
Okay.
Cheers, girl.
It's got some lemon, it's some apricot.
It tastes good.
I do like it is refreshing.
It would be really good in like a really nice day.
Yeah, it's like a warm day is refreshing.
Yeah, it's pretty smooth.
Tasting.
It is very smooth.
It is smooth.
No meat either.
But I can tell if it's too tart or it's not too sweet.
It tastes really good.
I like it.
I did too.
I definitely would buy that.
So red.
I don't have red.
I haven't much experience.
So usually it's too tart for me.
So we'll see.
It goes really well.
This taste really good.
It's good.
It is really smooth.
Okay.
This is like a good.
It burns your nose or you can just feel it and this does not.
Not any of that.
Yeah.
This is like a really good like fall wine, I feel like.
It's kind of cool.
Today's really cool.
Today's perfect day for this wine.
Yeah.
Let's go to the apple orchard.
This is like that.
That's more of a thing.
They're both good.
Yeah.
Very good.
Yes.
Well, that concludes today's episode.
So if you do want a nutritional supplement or a genetic consultation with us, please schedule
on Conor's Clinic.com slash shows.
We would be more than happy to talk with you and remember the first one is free.
So consultation with us, if needed or if you want or if you just want to stay high,
that's cool too.
But otherwise, make sure you like, subscribe and share this video, pass it along, share
with your friends, anybody who is a wine drinker, who maybe hasn't even heard of this.
That would be something cool to reach out and share with them.
Yeah.
Otherwise, that is it.
Thank you so much for watching and we'll see you next week.